you named Van Halen Van Halen why did
you do that well I think the original uh
name that they wanted was rat salad
which was the name of a Black Sabbath
song at some point in yeah
tribute band or something well let's
make something that's going to have some
longevity to it that has a little bit of
Shadow a little mystery you're not sure
what a Van Halen is it's like Santana
what is that could be the name of a
place it could be the name of a person
right but didn't that give the boys
didn't they give the Van Halen Brothers
a little too much power in the band like
that they had the name you know what I
mean I'm surprised you went with that
why not Roth
[Laughter]
single syllables never swing van raw Lee
Roth I don't know something all right
what was the song where you uh talked
about that you liked Black Silk
Stockings with the line running up the
back I think that's ain't talking about
love yeah every when I was working this
radio station women would just line up
because like Van Halen
every girl had black silk stockings on
with the machine and that was history
for all the wrong reasons too because at
that point in time I wasn't taking care
of most of my homework like I maybe
should have oughta right and they were
rewinding tape in the studio and our
producer at the time Ted templeman said
Dave are you ready to do the middle part
and I said sure well I always say sure
when he started to roll I didn't have
any lyrics prepared right and there were
a couple of gals sitting on the couch
you know on the other side of the glass
and I just started talking to him wow so
it just happened by accident I mean just
like like we just crossed the top of
your head well I'm never going to admit
I didn't do my homework right right
thank you